for decades the iss has been an icon
of international cooperation two bitter
enemies were able to put aside their
differences
and embark on a project that would
better all of humanity
after 23 years though the iss is
starting to meet its natural end
and russia feels that it's time to ditch
the iss and build their own national
space station
so here's how russia plans to withdraw
from the iss and their progress
on their next space station before we
get into russia's new space station
let's first take a look at why russia is
leaving the iss in the first place
starting with of course aging the iss
was mostly designed within the 1990s
and the first iss module was launched
way back in 1998
so at this point astronauts at iss are
basically using 20 to 30 year old
technology
nasa claims that there's still plenty of
research that can be completed with this
technology itself
but there's no question that new modules
with up-to-date technology
would make the process much smoother the
technology
is not the only component that's aging
either the overall body and exterior of
the iss is deteriorating
as well space is an extremely
unforgiving place with large amounts of
radiation
super cold temperatures and a plethora
of space debris
scientists did design the iss to
withstand all the harsh forces found in
space
but as the iss ages the likelihood of
some component giving in
is much higher just a few years ago
astronauts onboard the iss noticed a
drop in pressure
after a little digging they found that
there was a small hole in the walls of
the iss
they did quickly fix the issue and no
one was hurt but this
instant makes it clear that serious
problems can and have occurred
russia actually points to safety being
their primary reason that they are
leaving the iss
last month the deputy prime minister of
russia yuri borosov
stated we can't risk the lives of our
cosmonauts
the structure and metal are getting old
and it can lead to irreversible
consequences to catastrophe
another major consideration when it
comes to keeping the iss running
is funding the iss cost a massive 150
billion dollars to construct
we don't know how much money russia
spends on the iss every year
but we do know that nasa spends three to
four billion annually to keep the iss
operational assuming that ross cosmos
spends a similar amount
russia is throwing at least a few
billion dollars of iss every year
by implementing all of the experience
russia has gained from operating the iss
it's likely that they can build a new
space station that's much cheaper to run
something else to consider is that nasa
just recently stopped subsidizing
russia's portion of the iss
since nasa retired the space shuttle
they have been relying on soyuz rocket
to send us astronauts to the iss
it's estimated that between 2011 and
nasa spent a hefty 3.9 billion dollars
to fly us astronauts
on soyuz rockets this revenue no doubt
reduced russia's net input
into the iss but starting last year
nasa started to plan spacex for crude
iss missions
starliner also just completed its first
fully successful encode iss mission
so nasa now has two different options to
send astronauts to the iss
as a result i don't think they're going
to be buying tickets on soyuz
anytime soon meaning that russia has to
fork over more of their own money
to keep the iss running and this simply
doesn't make sense for russia when both
of them
and nasa are ready for the next step you
see the iss
is not the end goal when it comes to
space exploration the long-term goal is
to return to the moon
and get people to mars and so on and so
forth so
neither nasa nor russia are interested
in spending the majority of their effort
on the iss nasa is looking to finally
return humans to the moon in 2024
and russia is working on putting humans
on the moon by themselves by 2030.
in the meantime nasa is planning to open
up the iss to private astronauts and
tourists
while i don't think russia has any
objection against his plan
i also don't think they really care to
spend manpower on supporting this effort
long term so those are some of the
primary reasons that russia
is looking to ditch the iss fortunately
they're not just pulling out of their
partnership
without an ample warning time russia
said that they will confirm or extend
the departure date in 2025
meaning that russia has given the iss
partners a minimum of five years to
prepare for the departure
whether they leave in 2025 or 2030 is
really just dependent on how well their
own spaces and development goes
russia started working on this new space
station in 2015
and they hope to have it ready for
launch by 2025. if they're able to meet
this deadline
the next goal is to put the entire
station in orbit by 2030
at which point russia would completely
exit the iss something that we should
note though
is that russia said this exact same
thing six years ago with different dates
in 2015 russia announced that they were
going to leave the iss in 2020
and move into their own space station in
the early 2020s
but clearly that didn't happen so it's
very possible that these deadlines are
pushed back once again
i do think that russia is much more
motivated to transition now that nasa is
no longer dependent on them
however space technology almost always
takes longer to develop than expected
so a more realistic timeframe may be
completing the space station by 2030
and putting it into orbit by 2035. at
that rate
russia would stay on the iss for another
15 years nasa is looking to de-orbit the
iss in the 2030s or 2040s
so at that point russia may ironically
end up sticking with iss till the end of
its life
what will happen to russia's iss modules
though well
russia was originally discussing
disconnecting the modules and connecting
it to their upcoming space station
but given the age of the older modules
it's very possible that russia simply
retrieves some parts of them to be
placed in museums
and lets nasa deorbit the rest of the
iss anyway
moving on to the new space station
russia is aiming for the new space
station to cost just five billion
dollars
and it is being manufactured by energia
corporation the new station is called
the russian orbital service station or
ross the station is expected to have
three different docking ports
one for soyuz crude vehicles and two for
progress cargo ships
as for the core part of the station
itself we have five different modules
with the first being the airlock module
as the name suggests this module acts as
an air lock for the space station
but more importantly this module
contains a spacewalk hatch
next up we have the transformable module
this module
is unique as it can expand and constrict
its internal volume
once it's attached to the space station
there's really no reason to constrict
the volume of the module
by launching it in its constructor
orientation would save space on the
launch vehicle
this module is expected to have exercise
facilities and likely sleeping and
restroom facilities as well
as for the pritchell node module this
module is supposed to serve as the core
of the space station
and connect all the different modules
together the space station is also
slated to have a gyroscopic module
but we don't have details as to the
purpose of the module
anyway the last two modules are all
science and research modules
with the first being an awukka module
the naruka module was actually
originally designed to be docked with
the international space station
but russia decided to repurpose the
module to be used in their own space
station
this module is officially a
multi-purpose laboratory
but it also has a robotic arm a science
airlock a radiator
and a couple of orbital correction
engines finally we have the science and
power module which is apparently the
most advanced portion of the space
station
not only will it have leading edge
laboratories and flight control systems
but it will also offer extra living
quarters aside from all of these modules
the station will of course have solar
panels and propellant tanks to power the
station
and its engines the entire station is
estimated to have a pressurized volume
of 220 cubic meters
to put that in perspective the iss has a
pressurized volume
of about 1 000 cubic meters the russian
portion of the iss
is only 189 cubic meters though so the
ross is larger than the russian part of
the iss
but in comparison to the overall iss the
russian space station is about one-fifth
to one-fourth of the size
considering the smaller size of the
station it is estimated that two
cosmonauts will stay at the station for
two month periods
at a time russia plans to put the space
station in a lower orbit than the iss
in the 300 to 350 kilometer altitude
range aside from being in a lower orbit
the space station will also follow a
different orbital path the russians want
to put their station in polar orbit
in order to monitor northern sea routes
they're hoping to create new shipping
routes through the arctic
as the arctic ice melts on top of
creating new arctic routes
russia is looking to get a much better
view of mainland russia
right now russia is only able to view
about 20 of their territory from the iss
which has been one of their top
complaints from the very beginning with
the polar orbit though
russia should be able to view most of
their territory unlike with the iss
aside from building their own space
station for the earth russia is also
partnering with china to build a lunar
space station
this actually sounds extremely similar
to nasa's lunar gateway project
but russia isn't really interested in
participating in the lunar gateway
project
they say that the lunar gateway project
is way too ufcentric
they are however open to allowing other
nations to use their lunar space station
once it's complete but that's pretty
much all we know about the russian
chinese lunar space station
at this point in time at the end of the
day the iss was a revolutionary project
both scientifically
and diplomatically as the iss continues
to age and space technology continues
advanced though
it makes less and less sense to support
the iss especially with larger projects
around the corner
nasa themselves is looking to pull the
plug on the iss within the next 10 to 20
years
but it looks like russia isn't willing
to wait that long
so they're basically putting in their
five years notice as they look to build
their own space station within this
decade
this station isn't nearly as large as
the iss but
it is expected to be significantly
cheaper more efficient and much more
useful to the russians
aside from this they're also looking to
partner with china to build a lunar
space station
but we'll just have to wait and see how
that turns out what do you guys think
about russia's plan to ditch the iss
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited to see more
explanations being launched
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one